boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on we
are still on site in Manhattan in New
York City New York we are now by Central
Park we are super excited for this
episode and very grateful to be talking
about all things authoring being a New
York Times best seller doing things like
writing about your own human guinea pig
in your own quantifying self doing
things like gratitude all different
kinds of cool stuff we are sitting down
with AJ Jacobs hello hello Alan thank
you great to be here thanks a thousand
of course of course yes AJ Jacobs for
those that don't know is a New York
Times bestselling author he's the author
of six books which are all very
interesting highly recommend checking
them out the links are in the bio most
recently the author of thanks a thousand
which takes us through a really fun
journey of thanking everyone that's
involved in his morning cup of coffee
which ends up being pretty much
thousands and even more people which
we'll get to really excited to talk
about that as you guys know the
importance of gratitude it's huge and
he's also contributing editor for
Esquire and NPR and also a writer for
the New York Times and other magazines
AJ thanks a lot for coming onto the show
I'm super blessed for this episode I am
delighted to be here I'm a fan yeah yeah
okay all right let's start with we love
starting with big history synthesises so
okay
humans have now found themselves as
stewards of earth and here we are and
there's a complex civilization happening
how what is your synthesis on what's
going on in community I love starting
with a wide lens why not write I think
that's great well a couple of thoughts
one is that despite the flood of
negative news every day you know for 24
hours a day in the long view I do think
our species has done some good I'm in
the Steven Pinker camp that that overall
life is better the good old days we're
not good the good old days or the worse
they were violent sex
racist dangerous smelly I mean you just
read about New York City a couple
hundred years ago with the walls of
horse manure on the side of the streets
so that when I get depressed about or
annoyed about not getting wireless I
think I have a three word mantra which
is surgery without anesthesia because
that's like you know 100 if I were born
150 years earlier as one of the things I
would have to undergo so that's one side
of it overall I think the trend is in
the good direction but I do think that
we face an inflection point right now
where we've got the climate crisis and a
couple other things like AI where we we
need to make sure that we continue in
the right direction and we need to take
some drastic steps otherwise the
direction is gonna go right down so we
could we're on the verge I think of
either the most amazing time in human
civilization or the darkest time and so
it's kind of up to us okay great great
synthesis yes there is we live in great
times now we've done a good job building
this civilization a standard of living
is gone up a lot at the same time it's
time to for us to come together as one
this unity that we got to get to in
order to help get to the next thousand
years oh great yeah yeah and that's the
theme of a lot of my books because yes
yes yeah
tribalism is yeah things are is
dangerous notion yeah yeah because the
tribe is earth
yeah the tribe is earth or you could
even say the tribe is sentient beings
human beings so we don't know who else
there is but yeah but yeah that's we're
all we're all one tribe and yeah it's
unfortunate evolution did some things
right and some things not so good so
yeah tribalism is obviously had survival
value but now it's kind of working
against us we can now manipulate
people's emotions in neural prosthetics
so we can just embed empathy and
non-tribal and I'm all for it yes so we
have to figure out how to
actually move forward okay this is
actually this is good Segway until you
know you were saying that this is part
of what you write about in in the books
now this is this is very interesting
because AJ is one of those authors that
he his writing is all about a lot about
running experiments on its life right
exactly
the human guinea pig yeah yeah and tell
us about this human guinea pig angle
you're yeah in your most recent book you
were just talking with your son and your
son was like well if you were truly
dedicated that dad you would actually go
do it right that you were like okay that
to me is that yeah I mean to just a
backup I I love writing and I do love
writing first person about my experience
I mean my my childhood though was not
that interesting it was you know there
are some people like Frank McCourt can
write about their wild child that's in
Ireland mine was you know no so so I
figure if I want to write about myself I
got to put myself into some interesting
situations and that's what I do so I
will do an experiment if I'm interested
in knowledge I decided to read the
Encyclopedia Britannica from A to Z and
try to learn everything in the world and
what is the meaning of knowledge
religion I wanted to figure out about
religion so why not live it live by the
rules of the Bible like live as if
you're Moses so that and then the new
one as you mentioned is is about
gratitude the origin of the new one was
I had been reading all about how
important gratitude is and how we are
wired with a negative bias to note it
you know you hear a hundred compliments
and a single insult what do you remember
the insult so I I wanted to fight that
so I would say these prayers of
Thanksgiving before a meal I started a
ritual and practice but the trick is I'm
not religious I'm agnostic so instead of
thanking God I would say well I'd like
to thank the the people who made this
possible that the tomato farmer the
woman at the cashier at the grocer and I
would do this and
one of my sons rightly pointed out that
this was kind of lame because those
people are not in the apartment they
can't hear they're getting nothing out
of it if I were committed I would go out
and thank these people in person and a
little you know light bulb went off and
I was like that is an interesting idea
that could be a project a book so that's
when I spent the next six months going
around the world thanking everyone who
had even the tiniest part in my cup of
coffee because you realize it it is
hundreds thousands of people it's a you
know the farmer the barista the
biologist who worked on the coffee beans
the logo designer the trucker the guy
who painted yellow lines in the road so
that the truck didn't veer into traffic
you know it is it takes it doesn't take
a village to make a cup of coffee it
takes the globe so it goes back to this
theme of connecting and we are all you
know this tribalism is dangerous so that
was uh that was my most recent I love
how you come up with the ideas for this
and it's so inspirational because yeah
you aim to make your own life so
interesting that you can write about it
and then show people how to really
interestingly live quantifying
experiments that they can learn from
learn really important wisdoms from
right I hope done I try yeah the point
is I have I do it so you don't have to
but you can come along on the journey
and as you and I have talked about I am
I am a big believer and evangelist for
people experimenting on their own lives
and you don't need to go and grow a huge
beard like Moses and Lincoln be little
tweaks you can try a new toothpaste
every month you can take a new route on
your walk to work but but I do think the
more novelty you can introduce to your
brain the more supple the brain stays
the more creative the better you are at
solving problems the more compassion you
have when you can see the world through
different points of view so I am all for
it everyone experimenting with their own
lives
yeah yeah you heard that that that means
to change things up in your life more
frequently get new lenses on seeing the
world and that that's good that's good
it's also like a test like can you can
you do this for a year a lot of it is
like that's true you testing your own
limits and like can you bright you it
yeah I like that yeah it's like a goal
goal setting and absolutely well how did
you even decide on writing being
something that you were so passionate
about in the first place well I think I
grew up yeah I I wasn't athletic I
wasn't like a social superstar but the
one positive trait that I think I did
have was curiosity I loved reading about
the most random topics or going on field
trips I remember in high school I went
on a field trip to the Scientology
Center and I never believed in
Scientology but I just loved hearing
them make their pitch so I thought is
there a way I can continue this to be
curious professionally and writing
seemed one way to do it yeah yeah that's
good I like I like hearing the the
origins of writing stories because we're
quickly approaching on a big attention
economy and it's an it's important to
find ones medium video like the show
audio maybe like a podcast writing like
articles books etc posts and designing
cool illustrations like we were talking
about as well these are it's important
to find that medium because we want to
capture people's attention to let them
know hey we're saying important things
yeah and yeah say hope so but I mean one
thing that I like too is in the
experimental phase that we were talking
about I do like to dabble in different
media so you've done so many TED Talks I
like yeah I love giving and this is not
something that came naturally I hated
speaking I mean part
the reason I was drawn to writing is
because it's this solitary pursuit and
you know I wasn't very good on stage but
I I basically we can talk about this the
whole idea of of acting as if so I
forced myself to be like I you know what
I'm comfortable on stage even though I
totally wasn't and I now after years of
doing this I've come to love it and I
love speaking in public and doing
interviews my first interview on a radio
show was so bad that they had to cut me
off in the middle because I was
stuttering I just stuttered on one word
I would I forget what it was like aiiii
and after 30 seconds the DJ's okay thank
you that was a day Jake it was a boob
I'm out that's like oh that was one of
the worst most humiliating experiences
of my life but I pledge I'm gonna get
better that is such an important story
to share I'm so happy that you're so
comfortable with your story and
vulnerability to to share that because
it you went into a zone that was very
uncomfortable for you and you don't you
and you didn't turn around and say I can
never do this again you kept going
you persisted and that persistence has
now brought you to multiple Ted stages
and whatnot and you're so much more
comfortable speaking you're cracking
jokes you're making the audience laugh
as you're teaching them it's your real
content a super good now and for people
at home wherever you're watching this
take those risks even though we're not
going to be good right away on the first
three-pointer over time we become better
I love that you say that yeah that is a
big theme in in my life and in all of my
work is failure you know you're it's a
huge part of everything and people ask
me how I come up with my ideas and
partly it's a numbers game I you know I
do come up with a lot of ideas but 98%
of them suck they're just terrible and
dumb but there was that 2% that
resonates that works so yeah I'm always
and I try to teach my kids I try to tell
them about failure you know I come home
from work in a way I pitched this idea
and
the editor practically hung up on me and
that's okay cuz yeah I'll uh you know
you got it just as you say keep going
see what works what doesn't
yeah I'm glad you're taking that lesson
to the kids you also you mentioned this
I'm happy you did that you're the ideas
we always have so many ideas but I ideas
are you know worth pennies the execution
of them is worth everything and when you
when you're you're right that we
typically have lots and lots of them and
then we only pick a couple to actually
build on within our lives you've
specifically chosen the ideas that you
build on that have some sort of a value
for other people so rather than doing
things that may that people may see as
like why you know someone writing about
the childhood that may not have had that
interesting of a childhood right yeah
you decide to go I'm gonna go for a year
of reading the encyclopedia from A to Z
and I'm gonna I'm gonna write about what
that's like to do that process so I want
to actually go through some really happy
your ideas are so interesting that other
people can learn from what your
experiences are with them I want to
actually go through the the other books
you've authored in short bursts because
I want people to get an idea of what
it's like to come up with ideas that
other people may find valuable that they
can then potentially be inspired to come
up with their own ideas and make videos
or about them so let's love it let's go
through them so it's all relative
there's a deep ancestry of
interconnection with everyone right this
one was about family and and against
tribalism
it's all relative was a book that
started because I got an email out of
the blue a few years ago from this guy
who said you don't know me but I'm your
12th cousin and I thought of course he
was gonna ask me to wire $10,000 to
Nigeria but the but it turned out he was
legitimate and he's part of this group
of scientists and researchers who are
helping the build a family tree not it's
not a tree it's a forest the goal is to
connect every human being on earth in
one big seven billion person family tree
which is crazy it's a great like
a moon shot and right now they have not
they don't have they have about 150
million which is still an astounding
amount and you can go online and and
it's done through DNA testing through
sort of crowdsourcing and and you can go
on these sites and figure out how you're
related to someone you didn't think you
well the one I remember I am rises
Barack Obama is my fifth great aunt's
husband's brother's wife's seventh great
nephews so we're very close but I love
the whole idea of your Kevin Bacon we're
six degrees every and every one is Kevin
Bacon and that was why I was drawn to it
as a book as to explore this idea that
we are all connected and as as we were
talking about in this idea of us versus
them that definitely made sense
evolutionarily when you were a tribe but
now we've got these worldwide problems
like climate change we can't we don't
have that luxury of being tribal we've
got to all be the one tribe so this was
a nudge can we use this heuristic as a
nudge to make us more open to working
with others and there is some evidence
that then it works there's oh well they
did an experiment at Harvard where they
told Israelis and Palestinians how
closely they were related through DNA
and the ones who were told that were
more willing to work yeah and and we're
more open-minded and they go willing to
negotiate so there is some evidence that
this is a good sort of a good trick
heuristic nudge in the right direction
so that was that was that book and again
this is such an important put nudge in
the direction of unity of
interconnectedness of all of us coming
from a seed of life of seed of evolution
and here we find ourselves why are we
fighting yeah yes okay that's like that
so that's a really cool and I like that
one how about we talk about you know
living biblically this is all about
living by the Bible for a year taking it
at it
and and this came about because I grew
up in a very secular home as I say in
the book I I'm Jewish but I'm Jewish in
the same way the Olive Garden is Italian
no yes - ish emphasis on the ish exactly
but I was very interested in religion
and what to teach my kids you know and
why does half Thor two thirds of the
world believe and then it might have the
embraced rationality so I wanted to a
see what I was missing and can parts of
religion help with my life and B I
wanted to I think there's a very
dangerous stream of fundamentalism
people who say let's take the Bible
literally homosexuality is a sin because
there it is in the Bible and I want it
to show well you are taking parts of the
Bible literally but I'm going to show
you what it's like to take all the Bible
literally be the ultimate fundamentalist
you know stone adulterers I use pebbles
so I didn't get in jail but the Bible
says you cannot wear clothes of
different fabrics woven together so no
poly cotton blends you know the Bible
says you cannot say the names of pagan
gods so when you say something like
Wednesday or which is named after Odin
or the planet Venus you are committing a
really an abomination so I can't shave
you can't shave the corners of your
beard with the rule and I didn't know
where the corn is where are the courts
it's debatable
you gotta ask your but yes that was that
was the idea and I did so I wanted to do
both I wanted an earnest exploration of
what is what is good and unifying in
religion and what and also exposed that
we should not be closed-minded and
literal about it so and I do think there
are parts the the idea of community and
the an ethical behavior I like that but
in a secular context sort of like one
says Alan butene has that I say his name
he's a writer who talks about sort of
secular religion like
you know every Sunday coming together to
have a group of people and talk about
ethical issues and stories but you don't
need the the God component yep that's a
new big movement and again EJ is all
about nuance as you can tell so he's
finding good in the Bible and applying
it to his life and teaching people about
and he's also saying this is what
happens if you follow it fundamentally
and as a fundamentalist and then you
have to you encounter all these kind of
archaic esque I rules and so yes I love
that you say that we were involved
that's how we evolved right yeah and
yeah nuance is very hard in this and as
we were talking but you know it doesn't
it doesn't sell as much as like the
radical black and white but as we talked
about you know it's one of the few black
and white issues for me is that the
world is not black and white you know
the one of the only certainties I have
is that certainty is dangerous and you
do have to look at the the subtleties
yes the good and the bad yes yes
and then the know-it-all which is this
is something that I also did in my youth
not all the way a to z but it was
definitely lots of enjoying looking
through all the different entries in the
encyclopedia be nice is a great way to
learn about the world I love that you're
a fellow reader and I also love that you
say in your youth because you are still
in you do I am so impressed of what
you've done you're like at your age I
was I think you know my greatest
accomplishment was like eating three
pizzas I don't know what was but it was
not this but yeah this one was again I
wanted to try to imbibe all knowledge in
the world and see how it changed me what
wisdom I could come out with and it was
a so I read the Encyclopedia from A to Z
and it was a crazy long book it took me
a year and a half and that was I mean
there were dangerous to it I became a
little too enthusiastic about my
knowledge and my wife started to find me
she penalized me $1 for every year
in fact I inserted into conversation so
I definitely it was hard on me and on
the family but I do think there were
some takeaways
you know I've forgotten 99% of it but
but the bigger takeaways one is what we
talked about earlier the good old days
were horrible and another was this sense
of humility and Fishkin illogical
humility that there's so much we don't
know and you know even after reading the
encyclopedia even if I could remember it
there's still tons that's not in there
and realizing that I think it's very
important and not not and being open
mind not being a know-it-all and then
being in know acknowledging how little
we know and that's you know all these
sages throughout history have said the
same but it was astounding to me to read
about things that I barely heard about
or never heard about which are so
important to realize like the Taiping
rebellion in China which happened the
same time as our Civil War but our Civil
War kilts about six or seven hundred
thousand people in the Taiping rebellion
which was China Civil War 20 million
people died and I had barely heard of it
if at all I mean the only connection I
had was general so was the the leader of
the one of the Chinese armies and he is
famous for his chicken dish like that
was my only connection as General Tso's
chicken but it is a remarkable story and
20 million 20 million people and we
barely know about itself it is it was a
wake up call about how biased and our
information is and and again instead of
satiating my curiosity it just made me
more curious to keep learning this fit
into the 1% of things you retain because
it was just like an awakening like I
didn't know that 20 million people died
in the civil war in China right yeah
there was such mind-blowing stuff laying
there and that I knew so little about
yeah it's very humbling yeah yeah yeah I
do think humility is
and as I like to say I am the most
humble man in the world okay really
great at it okay how about how about my
life has an experiment that was an
anthology a collection of about 10
different experiments I did on myself
for a month each and one of them for
instance was this movement called
radical honesty where there's a
psychologist in Virginia who believes
that you should not you should never lie
but he goes further he says whatever's
on your mind should come out of your
mouth no filter so like if you have a
crush on your wife's sister you should
tell your wife and tell the sister so I
was like interesting so I tried it for a
couple of months and yes it was the
worst two months of my life
and because it's just not a great way to
go about for the marriage for dealing
with colleagues and bosses that said it
was not a waste of time because there
were some too so there is a way to be
radically honest that will enhance your
life I do believe like I don't believe
in saying everything like hey you know
the the classic your butt looks fat in
that dress is not helping the world but
I do think there's radical positive
honesty yes and that we don't do that
enough like acknowledging people or
thanking them work or you know calling
people a mentor that you haven't spoken
to in 15 years and saying how much they
meant to you so that was my takeaway on
radical positive radical honesty I love
how you jammed you were like I'm just
gonna jam 10 experiments it's a yeah
that was well it came back because I
used to write for ask or I do still but
I wrote a lot for Esquire and I thought
that I had 10 articles that I could put
together but when I went back and read
them I only had like four that I felt
held up so then I had to go do six more
so it was more work than I anticipated
but it turned out okay
and then drop dead healthy so this was
also quite the like it was quite
awakening because it also exposes how
unhealthy we really are in our
exercising habits and our eating habits
even in our in our stress habits things
like a noise pollution you pointed out
being something that is you were on on
the streets here in New York when you're
sustaining there across the street from
the the construction into the ground and
cabs are honking and it's just you
there's a big difference between that
and tranquil Lee sitting in a quiet
space
sorry sure yeah that was interesting I
did not know about the dangers of noise
pollution that was a physical that is
bad for your heart and there is some
research on it I wouldn't fund it at a
hundred percent but it's very
interesting research but that one
started just because I was in terrible
shape getting sick a lot and I I decided
my wife was said I don't want to be a
widow when I'm 40 years old you got to
do something so that's when I decided
like with the Bible I'm gonna dive in
and try to follow every piece of health
advice in the world which is of course
thousands and many of them contradict
each other but I decided to try
everything try every diet exercise
regimen and what I liked is that as you
would mentioned health is much wider
than just diet and exis not about
getting that six-pack abs it's about a
life well-lived and things like stress
is so important sleep is so important
and one of the big takeaways was friends
and a social circle yes it's okay yes
that like you know people who have a
tight-knit social circle or family or
friends are much healthier live longer
and and so that was part of the lesson
that there is you can't you can be
unhealthily obsessed with your health
like if you are all about spending all
your time at
sir sizing and finding just the right
organic stalk of asparagus that might
not be the best for your health because
you might be ignoring chances to go out
with friends and and bond and talk about
deeper issues so yeah there was a bit of
liberation in that being healthy
partially means not being obsessed with
being healthy yeah yeah there's there
were so many crazy ones in there
everything from you know wiping the the
remotes and the and the iPhones you know
because they're just they're just a city
of germs you're going on there there's
there's the amount of like a walking
helmet because there are some people who
adopt that statistical reason I have no
and the germs are interesting because I
think there's a middle ground I think
you know there is the danger of an
epidemic or pandemic and germs can be
very dangerous but on the other hand you
can go overboard and gotta build the
immune system oh yeah there is some
theory about that and I and I've
actually moved away from germophobia
partly yeah because our current
president is a germaphobe and I thought
about it and I think it reflects an
irrational strain of thinking a fear of
the different and the outside and there
are some really interesting studies
linking like the fear of immigrations to
germophobia like seeing that as like an
invasion from the outside so that I've
moved away from the being obsessed about
germs
although yeah we should wash our hands
and in that that's also one of the
reasons of of Hitler's sort of ideology
as well as the that there was inferior
sort of germs of other people that were
not as yeah exactly is very biological
all about like pure blood and like
yes so so this is another sort of of an
important like treat each other humanize
each other Union union of with evolution
with each other as we move forward and
figuring out how to best do that with
yeah yeah thank goodness we have some
decentral I'm a big fan of
decentralization technologies which I
think are going to be a big player in
this unity okay let's get to let's get
to thinks a thousand so this gratitude
journey is so crucial because there's
actually physiological effects that
occur with gratitude which after over
time actually become part you just you
you vibe with grow you vibe with it it
starts changing your essence and you
leave like a more positive wake behind
you yeah
well yeah I love the science behind it
was which is what originally was like oh
my god I gotta be more grateful because
it does it affects PETA there are
studies that show you recover more
quickly from illnesses and surgery when
you keep a gratitude journal or you know
you're more likely your to stave off
depression you sleep better you eat
better it's ridiculous how much it
affects every part of your life and I
was like oh because again I have the
negative bias and I still do I still
babble it every day all of us are just
so attracted to that one negative versus
the hundred and I think if you believe
the evolutionary psychologists which I
do in this case it had value you know
you wanted to really notice that lion
you wanted to notice the one poison
mushroom out of a hundred so but
unfortunately now that we don't live on
the savanna it can be a real impediment
to happiness yeah and so this this
journey in I think another crucial part
so like what I think the two main for me
for takeaways for things mm the in sheer
importance of leaving a positive week
behind you with gratitude
everywhere you go on a daily basis and
what that does to your physiology and
the world around you and the other one
is this just
profound understanding of the
interconnectedness of everything in
terms of globalization and how
commodities move around the world and so
this is this is so important because
it's not only the you know the farmer
and the beans at the location but then
it's the trucks that take that to the
actual store and then it's this thanking
everyone in the store thinking the
people that laid the asphalt that for
the trucker to drive thinking the
cashiers thinking there's so many people
and this is where you said that it can
be an infinite oh yeah I could have
written you know an 18,000 page book and
taken the next 60 years of my life to
thank all the people because yeah once
you go to the people who paint the
yellow lines in the road you know what
about who made the paint and who made
the buckets for the paint and you know
you could just go on and on forever and
I love that this idea of
interconnectedness and and I also think
it's important because I think one fear
is that being too grateful will make you
complacent you'll be like oh
everything's so wonderful I'm so
grateful for everything but actually the
evidence shows the opposite the evidence
shows people when people are more
grateful they are more pro-social
they're more willing to go out and pay
it forward trying to help others and I
found that because when I'm in a
depressed state you know I am focused on
how do I get out of this how do I you
know I'm not thinking about other people
I'm thinking about myself but the the
beautiful paradox is then one of the
best ways to get out of this is to help
other people and by helping other people
you it triggers some happiness in
yourself so anyway that that's just a
thought like that happiness I mean that
gratitude is is a spark for action it's
not just all about yourself it's all
it's a two-way street
yeah yeah and there's you mentioned the
come to the fear of being complacent but
then there's also another one which you
of course gave this really good
understanding of how it's
that's not but then there's also this
this sort of fear of being taken
advantage of potentially and whatnot but
I think if if we can get to a point
where enough of a Avalanche effect is
going on in the world of everyone dosing
up on love and gratitude there will be
no room for people to try and take
advantage because everyone will have
Avalanche defect into that love that's a
very nice thought I hope for that I mean
they hope so too I read an interesting
article about this notion of the
opposite of paranoia is called pronoia
and paranoia is the feeling everyone's
out to get you and crow neue is the
feeling that everyone is out secretly
trying to help you seriously is gravely
not true that everyone is out to help
you but I think there are people some
people who are out to help you like you
are so pro neue pro neue you know what's
interesting about that is that if you do
believe that you are a character in this
in a game in a simulation your levelling
up that you could potentially pronoia
with the creator of the situation and
then work your way to live a lot more
easily with these experiences around you
let's hope the the creator of the
simulation is a nice person and that's
like psycho yeah that's interesting yeah
that's a little pronoia yeah
I also want to I want to talk about some
of the very basic ways of bringing this
into into into our lives and and how it
sort of humanizes us on a deeper scale
when we we frequently we very
infrequently look at each other in the
eyes with this passion to understand how
the person became who they are right and
have a deep sense of of humanizing
I love that yeah I mean the first person
I thanked in my too for my coffee was
the barista who works at the local cafe
and
so I said you know thank you for my
coffee and she said thank you for
thanking me and I had to cut it off
there I didn't want to go into this
infinite loop but one of the things I
asked her about what it's like to be a
barista and she said it's not easy
because you're encountering people in a
dangerous state pre-cast nation and that
a lot of people don't even look up from
their iPhones they just like him the
credit card they treat her like a robot
and you know eventually maybe there will
be a robot barista but for now we have
humans and so she talked about the
importance of this that's two seconds of
eye contact to remind both of you that
you're human it's important for both of
you and it's such a small thing tiny you
know you're not gonna win a Nobel for it
but it it has such a big impact because
making eye contact with people you deal
with every day yep you know and there
was another I believe it's the Dalai
Lama that also has expressed a deep
amount of of when people come into the
sphere around him he can't just not ask
them about their lives hmm I love that
yeah so then that's how you when you're
walking yeah Vince otherwise if you're
walking on the street you'd have to stop
and ask every single person so there's
got to be some sort of it yeah
distinctions that you got to make
between who you want to talk to but like
when you do sit down and potentially
you're uber or lyft or when you're sit
in the front seat and actually strike up
a conversation with where the person is
from what their life is like when you're
passing over the card for a transaction
say you know thank you very much
you know right I loved it I actually
just heard about a an uber alternative
called I think it's called the blahblah
car where you can I mean the order a car
you can mark down whether you want to
talk or you just want to say hi or you
want silence so I thought I loved that
because some people you may not be in
them and there's some drivers that don't
want to talk to and there's drivers that
do want to talk so that's interesting
and there's the future of automation you
were mentioning
on a barista that is robotics that
already then already exists we already
have that in places like San Francisco
and one out but also there's the an
autonomous vehicles the mood sensing
capabilities of oaj is in a non
talkative mood is in a talkative mood
he'd like this type of music you'd like
this type of love that yes and I'm
equally I want to I want to touch okay
on as we as we as we exit on banks a
thousand I want to mention the
importance of globalization because we
have now and this is kind of also
writing on that Pinker argument the
better angels of our nature here we are
we are so much better off thanks to the
ability for us to be so deeply
interconnected for us to be able to move
things around the world with ease to
call each other around the world with
ease and I think this is a also a big
testament to that yeah you were able to
take commercial aircraft places use
Google Translate if you need yeah yeah
well I as we talked about earlier you
know everything is graze so
globalization does have downsides no
doubt I mean especially the American
lower middle class has been devastated
by globalization but I think as you say
the upsides historically outweigh it and
will continue to which is billions of
people lifted out of extreme poverty in
the last 50 years just this amazing
ability to sample other cultures and and
and go to other cultures so I am yeah I
am Pro globalization I realize it's got
downsides and we can work on making it
better but overall I'm like yeah let's
you know let's not react by closing off
and trying to stay in our little
containers which is a big movement now
of nationalism and
xenophobia but overall not good for the
human race we've done a lot of moving
too quickly I think in the last century
especially where our population on the
planet has exploded so much from a
billion to almost eight and here we find
ourselves not really taking the time to
slow down and think about how we're how
we're moving resources around the world
and how we're how how we're educating
children to have at least a bare basis
of language and fundamental skills that
enable them to to prosper through the
artificial intelligence age all this
different kind of stuff we're just we
kind of went through that hockey stick
and we're riding it without really
slowing down to a great point to think
about and there's only one experiment on
this earth happening and that's the
human experiment in the sense and and
there's no pausing or rewinding there's
no oh yeah yeah so you really focus on
getting our [ __ ] together in the next
okay I want a couple things on the way
out the first thing is I want you to
teach people why it's so important that
you've already mentioned it several
times but why is it so important to run
these quantified experiments on yourself
and what sort of in in when doing it
with a and with an intention of
experiments that can bring good insight
to you and other people when you share
with that right well yeah I'll just tell
my experience and I just find that it
makes my life so much better to try
things out and see what works because
even a failed experiment you're gonna
learn something from it and it could be
small for instance in in the Bible it
says no no gossiping and so I tried that
and yeah that is not easy you know that
is that is built into us and there are
some arguments to be made that some
forms of gossip are actually helpful to
humanity but I think that the the ten
see to go immediately to the negative
and get this shot and Freud out of other
people's misery is just terrible but but
it's been a week trying not to gossip at
all just saying positive things about
people and I guarantee you it'll be so
hard but so rewarding so as we talked
about in the brain neuroscientists their
cat's phrases win it when it fires
together it wires together so when you
do the same thing over and over then you
build these pathways these ruts in the
brain and sometimes it's good because
it's a shortcut but other times you get
stuck in one way of thinking so that's
why I feel it's important to try
different things and I feel just on a
global level trying out more policies or
you know the environment I was just
listening to Dylan Matthews great
podcast future perfect about
bioengineering and are we going to have
to start experimenting with you know
creating fake volcanoes to cool down the
earth and I think we got to be open to
it because we are we can't we can't
dismiss it just because it's not natural
that's like a naturalistic fallacy we've
got to experiment you're you urge people
to push themselves into experimentation
which then gives them a again a sort of
you there that you're kind of playing
with life in a way in an in a new and
more interesting way you're getting
yourself out of a routine and you're
being more creative and yeah there's a
lot of good here agree so much good okay
couple these are questions we usually
ask on the way out of every show and and
I'm interested to hear your thoughts of
your answers on these questions all
right I'll do my best okay what is a
core driving principle of yours I would
say don't be a jerk in laughing fan of I
would say when I try to make decisions I
to think in four quadrants so the first
is how will it affect me now how it'll
affect me in the future how well the
fact other's happiness now how will the
fact others in the future and I think
for the first when I was your age it was
all about the first two but as I I've
gotten older I try and it's hard to
focus on the other quadrants about other
people so yeah you know I am basically I
I do try to think what is the greatest
good for the greatest number and it's
not an easy it's not an easy but it's
it's a good goal well being is a good
goal and nihilism is not that great
nihilism will get you literally nothing
would you even have a breakdown of
slowing down and thinking which is great
it's so great oh yeah I'm a fan of
that's good yeah the idea of savoring is
another big part of my my core principle
like let seeing yourself in your life as
a collector of experiences yes a curator
like you have a museum in your mind and
you try to collect experiences yeah yeah
and you also talk about how doing things
like retaining a sense of gratitude over
a long moment right and yeah I can make
that time feel like it's extenders for
sure slowing down telling them yeah yeah
you have that breakdown is both for your
own short-term versus long-term and then
others as well I like that a lot
okay how about if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch how would you
design it I love that question I was
just thinking about this yesterday about
language so I could focus on a million
things but let me just focus on language
for one thing because I think one
strategy I would use is to redesign
language so that there is no word for I
believe it would be everything would be
probabilistic there would be one word
for I believe ten percent and another
for I believe eighty four eighty percent
sure of this
I'm forty percent sure of this because I
think that would be so huge in
acknowledging that we are not sitting
like if we can just put in the word
probably into if we can use that word or
instead of certainty then we've got room
to negotiate and figure out solutions so
I would change language so that is it
has built-in probability and also I
would the emphasize nouns because like
when you say that guys such an [ __ ]
that's like saying he's he was national
he is national he will be an [ __ ]
it's very essentialist whereas i would
try to change it to that guy right now
is acting in an [ __ ] like manner and
that gives you the opening like maybe
he's not always bad maybe we can help
change him and he will be and I think
that's very important so fewer nouns
more probability that's good that's good
thanks yeah I like how you took it from
the language and probabilities
perspective that's good I like that
that's great okay how about this
wouldn't be simulation if we didn't ask
you are we in a simulation it's a good
question I don't know the I mean
sometimes I see the Elon Musk argument
that the probability is that we are I
mean I if we are I really would have
some words for the guy doing the
simulation and it's like you can do
better than this like it's like some of
the stuff that's happened in the last
year is like a second-rate screenwriter
you know like having I will tell you
this when Donald Trump was elected it's
for me was some evidence that of the
multiple world theory multiple universe
because I was always thinking if we live
in infinite universes why is our
universe not weirder like why don't I
have like a purple elephant
crashing through that bookcase right now
because it could happen and then like
this reality show host who's like a
caricature of everything it became
president and I'm like that's weird like
that that there are other universes
looking at us like you you were the
universe where Donald Trump became
president so anyway those are my random
thoughts I like that that many worlds
interpretation of the multiverses and
where we have that that weird the weird
line of code that was executed in ours
which ended up being so last question AJ
yes what's the most beautiful thing in
the world
oh well that's a lovely question I would
say well I do think about beauty I mean
one thing is I do think that the beauty
bias of treating attractive people
better is a terrible thing so and that's
like everything as is Gray's blacks and
whites
I do think beauty in that sense is a bad
thing because you know like it's not
something you can control and I think
like ugly people the discrimination
against them is just horrible so I would
say that in general about beauty but in
terms if you think about beauty in terms
of more conceptual like not physical
beauty but conceptual Beauty I would say
one of the most beautiful things to be
is when people have a conversation and
come to an understanding that is pretty
amazing to me and that we can do that
and we need a lot more of that yeah
discourse that ends with people's the
connection connection but thanks people
yeah and and a changed mind which is
very hard to do you know we are really
bad at changing our minds so that is one
of my goals as I you know for
a couple of decades I'm gonna be trying
to change my mind yeah when the evidence
shows that's a great way to wrap this
has been such an honor and a pleasure AJ
my pleasure I loved it
you are a huge role model for so many of
us oh yeah thanks we got it we got to
learn how to better run these
experiments in our lives and and and
gains positive in positive just learn
more about about ourselves in the world
that we live in by running these
experiments and just do this this mode
this most recent one is so crucial
thanks a thousand this is so so
important of course yeah yeah yeah cuz
how how else can we build up these
behaviors of gratitude around our world
and also realize the interconnectedness
of our world there's so much good to
take away from AJ's books go and check
out the link in the bio - AJ's work also
we would love to hear from you let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
build up the community build up the
dialogue amongst each other about some
of the things we talked about also go
and build go and run these experiments
tell yourself you're gonna do something
for a we can go do it for a week and see
how it is and then go write about it or
do a video about it and share it with
your friends and yeah build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone and help join simulation also
below we would love your help in helping
us scale everything that we're doing so
we can continue coming on site to great
places like this to talk to him using
people like AJ thanks again everyone
much love and we will see you soon
thank you for watching thank you
I'm very grateful for you I'm very
grateful for this interview I'm very
grateful for the people that made this
equipment we could do that for like six
or seven hours yeah I love it I love it
the years doing the fakes at the
beginning of dinner and then it and then
it goes into it's never eating roots
yeah okay all right all right all right